make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
today we are going to make a video from
a series that we haven't done for quite
a while how to kill superheroes well in
this case how to kill supervillains
here's the fun thing about this right
for those of you guys who are new we
haven't done this video series in about
a year this initially started off with a
series of videos on the Xavier protocols
right how Xavier plan to kill each one
of the x-men if things went awry and
then I don't know exactly where we went
from there it was like we chose like
superheroes who were not part of the of
the Xavier protocols and then people
started asking me to kill superheroes
and it's always like okay I guess we can
and then we just sort of going with like
all these different superheroes that it
became super villains and a sort of
differentiating differentiating between
the two we just kept the name how to
kill superheroes but it also includes
villains and even like cosmic entities
and different things like that this was
a cool series in this video because of
the fact that we haven't done this for a
long time and a lot of people have been
requesting this request me to bring it
back I figured we kick things off by
figuring out a way to kill one of the
most ridiculously powerful characters in
the history of the moral universe the
marquee of death
so before we figure out how to kill him
we have to go over who the marquee of
death is and what makes him so hard to
kill now those of you guys who want a
more comprehensive discussion on his
character you'll find the link to that
down in the description and the beyond
omega-level series but on this one this
was gonna be a little more skim down so
the marquee of deaths origin is actually
a little complicated because he is an
alternate universe version of a
character that already exists outside
the main Marvel continuity and what I
mean by that is the origin of the
marquee of death is actually the origin
of Clyde Winchell who first appeared in
Marvel 1985 number 2 written by Mark
Waid in 2008 now Clyde when Cham resides
on earth 1218 which is supposed to
represent our world where superheroes
simply don't exist with the exception of
the guys in Seattle what's the name of
that guy and I cannot remember his name
but he's that one dude he kicked it all
off but he was that one dude who was
like going around at night as a
superhero and like like stopping crime
he was like calling the cops in stuff
like that he wasn't beating anybody up
it would have been cool but anyway it
turns out that in that universe Clyde is
actually the lone mutant of his
particular erth erth 12-18 now Clyde's
mutant powers allow him to warp reality
and when he accidentally resurrects his
father from the dead because mother
freaks out and hits him in the head with
a candlestick which causes him to suffer
severe brain damage and as a result
Clyde is placed in a nursing home and he
gets so mad when his coming books are
taken away that he uses his powers to
summon a bunch of Marvel super villains
to his universe to punish those who had
wronged him now he later puts an end to
their rampage by simply uttering the
word enough summing all of them back to
the earth-616 universe but Clyde himself
also turns up in the 606 universe where
he's found by Reed Richards who places
him in a catatonic state
in a holding facility called area 97
where Clyde experiences a constant
stream of pleasant dreams which sounds
like a great solution with a problem
having brain damage with regards to a
reality-warping mutant but the problem
with this is that in the alternate
universe where Hyde escapes from area 97
after a group of villains come to kill
him but accidentally repair his brain
damage Clyde ends up killing them all
with a single thought and so after
Claude kills these villains he begins to
develop a desire to cause destruction
now I also need to point out here that
Clyde is immortal so he devotes billions
of years to honing his powers and
learning to control time and space and
he eventually evolved into the marquee
of death that travels throughout the
multiverse destroying every universe
that he comes to and so we know just
from that bit of information but killing
the marquee of death an entity capable
of destroying entire universes is going
to present us with quite a challenge but
before we get into that we need to go
over what the Marquis is capable of
which is really probably what a lot of
the guys are really interested in and so
as we discussed earlier the marquee of
death is capable of reality warping and
he's an incredibly powerful reality war
for a fact as he was able to summon lots
of super villains to his universe and
then banished them back to their own
universe now among the villains he's
summoned and subsequently banished was
Galactus who was a cosmic entity who
devours entire planets to survive and
Clyde winter was able to summon him at
will now keep in mind that was before
Clyde even became the marquee of death
and so after becoming the marquee he
goes from universe to universe
destroying everything in his path for
instance in one universe he simply waved
his hand destroyed the Sun and thereby
destroyed the entirety of the universe
itself
he's able to travel through time as we
saw when he traveled to the prehistoric
age to feed dr. doom to a Megalodon
shark
he's also an exceedingly powerful
telepath and was able to show Johnny
Storm memories from alternate universe
versions of his sister Sue Storm dying
as a form of mental torture and on
another
occasion he created an entire world
inside of dr. Doom's mind that doom
believed he'd spent years in but in
actuality all of it had only lasted a
matter of seconds
and so the Marquis can manipulate matter
on a molecular level as he did when he
turned dr. Doom's heart to stone and his
blood to acid he was also able to alter
the planet's climate causing tropical
regions to freeze and glaciers to
erupted with lava he's able to
manipulate reality in such a way that he
changed the timeline of events that had
already occurred offering Reed Richards
a chance to save the earth by allowing
his son Franklin to be stillborn or by
allowing Ben Grimm to have died in the
accident that gave the Fantastic Four
their powers now when Reed refuses the
Marquis final offer of killing the
version of Clyde winch him that's still
in a coma within area 87 in exchange for
saving all the universe's destroyed by
the Marquis he's able to summon the
Fantastic Four's of a million universes
to the main Marvel Universe to fight
that version of the Fantastic Four but
notably the best indicator we have of
the marquees absurd power level is the
chess match that he has with the younger
version of himself Claude wynjym where
they use Thanos Odin ego the Living
Planet
Mephisto Galactus and eternity as their
chess pieces now these characters are
really really high up on the Marvel
power hierarchy so the fact of the
Marquee can simply just move them around
it will like a literal chess piece is
really insane when you think about it
and it lets us know but he's one of the
most powerful entities to have ever
existed in the history of the Marvel
multiverse so the question becomes how
do you possibly kill a being that's so
powerful but he has literally destroyed
millions of universe as well as it turns
out even though the marquees powers are
vast they are not infinite we see during
the final battle with the Fantastic Four
that if enough strain is placed on the
marquee of death he could be weakened in
fact once he is sufficiently weakened
he's actually killed by Doctor Doom
albeit a version of doom that has
survived since being eaten by Megalodon
in the Pliocene age and been honing his
skills ever since but still we know that
it is possible to kill the marquee of
death but the problem is it takes a lot
of energy to do so now prior to the
Marquis death
the Fantastic Four battled him after
draining the powers of all the other
versions of themselves that have been
brought to the main Marvel Universe and
so having to battle what was in essence
an army of Fantastic Four's
significantly
in the marquee but the real turning
point was when the Human Torch hit him
with a blast that was beyond supernova
level as that blast reached planked
temperature which is roughly 100 million
trillion trillion degrees Kelvin which
Reed Richards described as being the
opposite of absolute zero and explains
that at that temperature time and space
breakdown and the Marquis powers are
negated and so after the Marquis is hit
with that blast he's weak enough to be
killed and so there we have one way of
taking out the Marquis of Death we
simply have to hit him with enough
energy to sufficiently weakened him of
course in practical terms this is
extremely difficult to do and require
the Human Torch to absorb the power of
thousands or possibly millions of other
versions of himself to produce an
adequate amount of energy but since this
is comic books we're not really bound by
practicality and so uplink temperature
is merely theoretical in the real world
there are so many great minds in the
marvel universe including Reed Richards
Tony Stark Black Panther and Bruce
Banner that they would definitely find a
way to harness some of the multiple vast
sources of energy that exists within the
Marvel Universe like the quantum field
for example or the odinforce or the
power cosmic and direct all of them at
the marquee of death to take him out the
short of that we'd really have to rely
on an entity more powerful than the
marquee of death which would probably
have to be the one above all or the
linee tribunal since we've seen that the
marquee appears to be more powerful than
all of the other cosmic entities like a
lactis in eternity or we could use the
powers of one of the other reality wars
in the Marvel Universe like Flint in
Richards or the molecule man to simply
imagine him out of existence but that's
not fun that's kind of boring oh that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys with
the sub button to become part of the Rob
poor if you guys want to see this series
return let me know down in the comments
by posting up a character that you want
me to kill and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]